so if you're a longtime viewer me you
probably know that I have a huge crush
on Emma Stone and think she's incredibly
hot so I want to get all of it out right
now
and just just have it all right here in
my review because you know I want to
talk about it my daughter in the
restaurant of you so here we go
I got a job today
Ratan for the Jackson Journal great you
can write my obituary Charlotte Phelan
dad her daughter still single the help
stars Emma Stone Viola Davis Octavia
Spencer Bryce Dallas Howard and Jessica
Chastain and started by Tate Taylor its
based out of a national bestseller takes
place in Mississippi back in the olden
days and people were absolute idiots
Emma Stone decides to interview a group
of black maids to try to get their
viewpoint in life to the public so
people can see how horribly they're
treated and how inappropriate things
that go on behind those families closed
doors are so she can hopefully reach the
minds of the public and and get a
different viewpoint get the viewpoint of
the help because that's portrayed in
this film things were so unfair for them
that it bordered on absolute inhumanity
Viola Davis and Octavia Spencer plays to
the housemaids that Emma Stone starts
interviewing and they each have a lot of
different entertaining stories to tell
and they create such a wonderful
relationship with each other such a bond
and it's portrayed really realistically
it's not portrayed sapling or anything
it's not like oh you know whatever is a
lifetime original movie or something
I have drafted the home health
sanitation initiative for wood i bill
that requires every white home to have a
separate bathroom for the help
hey we should just build you a bathroom
outside Haley I really enjoyed the help
it was a very heartfelt film and it was
it was heartfelt in just the right way
it was realistic to the point where you
can tell that a lot of this really went
on this way and it shocks me to my core
how close we are in history to this time
period when this absolute monstrosity of
human thinking was going on it's just it
blows my mind that people used to be
like this and unfortunately some still
are today I was so happy to see Emma
Stone in this movie because I've always
liked her in comedies and you know she
had a bit of a physical role in
Zombieland but this is the first time
we've really been able to
your dramatic chops and she's excellent
in this film she gives a great
performance and it's not just because
I'm a huge fan boy but no she's really
good in the movie layla davis is just
fantastic in this movie she gives such a
heartfelt performance it's so much
emotion is in her face and she is so
good at being able to hide that from the
people that she works for but you can
still see it as a viewer you see it in
her eyes and she's not talking there's
not dialogue and you can just see it in
her face this is a brilliant performance
Octavia Spencer is also very good in the
film she got a lot of laughs from the
audience in the movie Minnie hey boy hey
Manny mm-hmm Bryce Dallas Howard is
essentially the villain of this movie
and she is basically Satan mother of
pearl her character is awful in this
movie she is just the lowest common
denominator of a human being I gotta
give her credit she plays it so well it
was kind of interesting to see her and
Emma Stone face off because I realized
in the movie wait a second Emma Stone is
the upcoming gwen stacy bryce dallas
howard was the former gwen stacy in the
spider-man movies and now they're facing
off in one movie this is interesting
Jessica Chastain and Sissy Spacek are
also really good in the film and they
they're both really cute characters that
you just you like it you need characters
like that in this movie I know most of
the screenings the audience gets really
into it but I can tell the audience
really connected with this movie I won't
give anything away but the final scene
in this film is brilliant it's executed
in such a fantastic way performances had
my eyes just completely glued to the
screen and I actually teared up a little
bit and that's saying something because
I very rarely do that you said you're
right about what disturbs me
particularly if it bothers no one else
I'd like to read something from the
point of view of the help I want to
interview you
I was thinking about not starting my new
rating system that I've been planning on
doing until January of next year but you
know what I'm gonna start it now the
help gets a B+ from me I really enjoyed
the movie so yeah my new rating is now
we're gonna be letter grades I'm I'm
sick of doing the four star doesn't
doesn't have enough of a range for me
everyone does five stars so I'm not
going to do it a lot of people do ten
stars that's just way too much I'm gonna
do letter grades I'm gonna be the one
guy doing letter grades so me and
Richard Roeper yeah we'll do it help
comes out on Wednesday it's a great
movie fantastically active very well
directed really well-written I haven't
read the book in case you were wondering
but definitely suggesting the film it's
really good so if you liked my review
subscribe to my channel and get stuck
mine eyes